Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 37. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe. Ich bin wie schon bei der letzten Sendung hier im Standort Oberpfaffenhofen des DLR und möchte heute ein Projekt sprechen, was hier schon sehr häufig zur Sprache gekommen ist, aus den unterschiedlichsten Gründen heraus. Und was sich auch von ähnlichen Missionen doch trotzdem auf bestimmte Art und Weise deutlich unterscheidet. Konkret soll es gehen hier um zwei Satelliten, die im Pärchenflug die Erde umrunden, TerraSAR oder auch TanDEM-X. Da gibt es auch einige Sprachverwirrungen, die wir gleich mal aufklären wollen. Und dabei hilft mir Manfred Zink. Du bist hier Projektleiter für das Bodensegment TanDEM-X. Also quasi hier die Steuerung von der Erde aus. Und auch schon von Anfang an bei dem TanDEM-X-Projekt mit dabei. Sehe ich richtig.
Ja, ich war bei den Vorphase-Studien nicht dabei. Da war ich kurz bei der ESA, aber seit 2005 bin ich dabei.
Wie bist du überhaupt so hier hergefunden auf diese Position?
Ich habe an der Technischen Universität Graz Physik studiert und bin dann schon 1987 hier nach Oberpfaffenhofen gekommen für meine Diplomarbeit und habe in diesem Zeitraum dann auch hier eine Stelle gefunden und bin seit 1988 eigentlich im SAR, also im Synthetik-Apertur-Radar-Geschäft tätig. Meine ersten Missionen waren die SIRSI-XA-Missionen auf dem Space Shuttle. 1994 gab es da zwei Flüge, an denen ein deutsches X-Band-Radarsystem hier als Payload auf dem Space Shuttle. Die Mission, oder eine Erweiterung dieser Mission, die sogenannte Shuttle-Radar-Topography-Mission, ist dann in 2000 nochmal geflogen, da war ich auch noch dabei, da war ich sogar im Kontrollzentrum in Houston als Teammember des deutschen Anteils. Ich war dann für fünf Jahre bei der ESA, habe da im Envisat-Projekt gearbeitet. In Esteg, in Nordwijk, in Holland. Ich war dort auch für die Inbetriebnahme des Radarsystems, also auch ein SAR-System auf Envisat, das AASA zuständig. Und habe dann in einer sogenannten Phase B, also Vorstudie, für ein TerraSAR-L gearbeitet. TerraSAR-L war eigentlich als Pendant zum TerraSAR-X gedacht. Also man wollte eigentlich ursprünglich eine X-Band-Komponente und eine L-Band-Komponente realisieren. Das L-Band ist leider nicht weiterverfolgt worden. Aber X-Band, TerraSAR-X, den gibt es und darum sitzen wir hier.
Ja, es sind schon ein paar interessante Begriffe gefallen. Vor allem Radar scheint da dein wissenschaftliches Leben von Anfang an zu begleiten. Was gab es da eigentlich einen Grund für?
Ja, ich war im Physikstudium schon im Bereich der Elektrodynamik spezialisiert und bin eigentlich hier dann eingestiegen, Antennen zu berechnen mit numerischen Verfahren. Und hatte da schon natürlich eine gewisse Richtung. Ich war auch in Österreich schon in der Schulausbildung schon in Richtung Elektrotechnik fokussiert. Also da gibt es sogenannte Mittelschulen, die technisch orientiert sind, also weniger Gymnasien wie hier, sondern man hat da schon irgendwie eine Vorprägung erhalten. Also war eigentlich meine Richtung immer schon vorbestimmt.
So, jetzt hast du gesagt, SAR, das steht für Synthetic Aperture Radar. Also was heißt das genau?
Ein Radar mit synthetischer Apertur? Man kann sich so vorstellen, je größer, je länger diese Antenne ist, umso feiner ist die Antennenkeule, die Ausleuchtung am Boden, umso besser können wir Objekte trennen, auflösen. Jetzt hat unser TerraSAR zum Beispiel eine Antenne von 5 Meter Länge, da ist der Fleck am Boden mehrere Kilometer groß.
Ja.
Synthetisch wird die Apertur jetzt dadurch, dass der TerraSAR im Orbit eine gewisse Bahn entlangfliegt und dann sammelt er Reflexionen von den Objekten über einen längeren Zeitraum. Und die können wir verbinden, verknüpfen und dadurch eine sehr lange, eine kilometerlange synthetische Apertur bilden und im Endeffekt am Boden Objekte in der Größenordnung von 1 Meter auflösen.
Apertur-Öffnung kennt man ja jetzt aus dem optischen Bereich.
Genau, das ist wie die Öffnung der Kamera. Das heißt, ich habe eine sehr große Öffnung dieser synthetischen Antenne, weil ich die einzelnen Pulse, die da empfangen werden, die kann ich miteinander verknüpfen, die kann man verrechnen und kann dadurch eine sehr große, eine kilometerlange Apertur erzeugen.
Warum kann man das jetzt ohne diese Technik nicht machen? Also ich meine, wie funktioniert jetzt ein normales Radar und was ist bei dem SAR jetzt dann konkret anders?
Konkret anders ist, dass ich eben die Reflexionen aufzeichne. Das Wichtige beim Radar ist, Radar ist ein kohärentes System. Das heißt, wir messen nicht nur die Stärke, wir nennen es die Amplitude der Reflexion, sondern wir messen auch die Phase, die hat mit der Entfernung zu tun. Wir senden ja Wellen aus und die Phase bestimmt mir quasi, wo in der Welle, an welcher Position in der Welle ich mich da befinde. Und diese Phaseninformation kann man nutzen. Und wenn ich das für mehrere Pulse nacheinander mache und die entsprechend verrechne, kann ich eben diese synthetische Apparatur bilden.
In welchen Frequenzbereichen kann man Radar betreiben? Also wann macht das Sinn?
Wir arbeiten im Weltraum. Es gibt Systeme vom L-Band, das sind ungefähr 23 cm Wellenlänge, bis zum X-Band, das sind eben unsere Radarsatelliten und die arbeiten bei 3 cm Wellenlänge.
Und das normale Radar, was zwingt einen jetzt dazu, so etwas wie SAR zu machen? Also was verändert sich dann konkret?
Weil ich eben mit dieser kleinen, relativ kurzen Antenne, 5-Meter-Antenne, diese hohe Auflösung erzielen kann.
Für die man normalerweise eine längere bräuchte.
Genau, ich müsste ansonsten eine riesige Struktur in den Weltraum bringen, was natürlich sehr aufwendig und sehr teuer wäre.
Ah, verstehe. Und wodurch erzielt man jetzt diese Änderung?
Eben durch dieses spezielle Verfahren, das heißt, dass das System, das SAR-System, sendet mit einer sehr hohen Frequenz. Wir arbeiten bei ungefähr 3000 bis 6000 Hertz. Mit dieser Frequenz sendet das System Pulse aus und empfängt die Reflexionen. Und diese reflektierten Pulse werden eben dann verrechnet. Wir setzen da auch noch die genaue Kenntnis über die Orbit, über die Bahn des Satelliten ein und können damit dann die Fokussierung oder die Bündelung dieser Strahlen herstellen und die hohe Auflösung errechnen.
Okay, also das Ziel der Sache ist, dass man eben mit möglichst geringen Antennengrößen aus dem Weltraum auf der Erde möglichst genaue Messungen machen kann und da hilft diese SAR-Technik weiter.
Genau, da ist noch ein ganz interessanter Nebeneffekt. Und zwar kann ich im Prinzip die Länge der synthetischen Aperture dadurch gegeben, wie groß der Beleuchtungsfleck am Boden ist. Weil ich muss ja ein Objekt, kann ich nur so lang verfolgen, solange ich es wirklich mit der kleinen Antenne beleuchte. Diese Beleuchtung wird aber mit der Entfernung immer größer, weil quasi die Keule, die hat eine gewisse Öffnung und die wird immer größer. Das hat umgekehrt den Effekt, dass diese Auflösung unabhängig von der Entfernung ist. Das heißt, ich kann diese 1-Meter-Auflösung sowohl vom Flugzeug erreichen, als auch aus dem Orbit, aus 500 Kilometer Höhe mit dem Satelliten. Und das ist natürlich ein sehr interessantes Feature dieser Technik.
Wann ist das das erste Mal zum Einsatz gekommen?
SAR-Systeme, der erste SAR-Satellit wurde 1978 von der NASA betrieben oder in den Orbit geschossen. Auf Flugzeugen gibt es das wohl schon seit den 50er Jahren.
Also eigentlich nichts Neues?
Eigentlich nichts so dramatisch Neues, aber im Weltraum gab es, sag ich mal, bis zu Jahrtausendwende nicht so viele Satelliten. Wir hatten, glaube ich, im Jahr 2000 hatten wir zwei oder drei Satelliten. Mittlerweile haben wir, glaube ich, 15 Satelliten. Also man sieht auch, die Technik ist hochinteressant und auch durch diese hohe Zuverlässigkeit, das heißt, ich kann unabhängig von Tageslichtbedingungen, von Wetter immer wieder Daten aufnehmen, ist natürlich sehr wichtig für operationelle, systematische Beobachtung von unserem System.
Werden denn diese SAR-Systeme jetzt nur für Erdbeobachtungen? Also das ist der primäre Einsatzzweck Erdbeobachtung? Oder gibt es da auch noch andere Anwendungsfälle?
Es gab solche Systeme auch schon auf anderen Planeten, zum Beispiel die Venus wurde mit einem SAR-System kartiert, ist übrigens dadurch auch global gesehen besser vermessen als die Erde im Moment.
Oh, wirklich?
Ja.
Also feiner aufgelöst?
Genau, und genauer in der Höhe.
Ah, welches System war das bei der Venus?
Das hieß Magellan.
Magellan, aha, okay. Also Planetenbeobachtung könnte man mal sagen. Könnte man ja auch machen, genau. Und primär geht es um Höhenmessung.
Das ist ein wichtiger Aspekt, aber es geht natürlich, es fängt an mit den einfachen Radarbildern. Also wir bilden ja, wir machen richtig zweidimensionale Abbildungen, also man kriegt ein Bild des Objekts oder der Szene, die wir, das Streifen, den wir da abbilden. Wenn wir jetzt aber mehrere dieser Aufnahmen kombinieren, da gibt es eine sehr interessante Technik, die hat wieder mit dieser Eigenschaft der Kohärenz zu tun. Wir können eben diese Phasen auswerten. Und da gibt es zwei Spielarten. Und zwar kann ich Radarbilder aufnehmen und unsere Satelliten bewegen sich auf bestimmten Orbit, TerraSAR und TanDEM, zum Beispiel in einem Elftage-Wiederholzyklus. Das heißt, nach elf Tagen sieht er ein bestimmtes Gebiet genau unter den gleichen geometrischen Bedingungen. Das heißt, am gleichen Ort im Orbit. Und wenn wir die zwei aufnahmen, dann können wir sehr genau Bewegungen der Erdoberfläche bestimmen. Wir reden hier vom Millimeterbereich. Also die Verschiebung der kontinentalen Massen vermessen. Genau, zum Beispiel sehen wir Bewegungen, die durch Absenkungen, die durch Grundwasserentnahme oder durch Bautätigkeit, U-Bahn-Bau in Städten und so weiter ergeben sich Absenkungen. Die können wir sehr genau vermessen. Das ist auch schon gezeigt worden, wir sehen zum Beispiel Gebäude, Stahlkonstruktionen, die sich durch Temperatureffekte ausdehnen, im Sommer quasi wachsen um, keine Ahnung, 5 Millimeter, 1 Zentimeter und im Winter wieder ein bisschen schrumpfen. Das gibt ein sehr schönes Beispiel vom Hauptbahnhof in Berlin.
So eine große Stahl-Glas-Konstruktion.
Genau, das ist jetzt mal eine dieser Spielarten.
Das heißt, man sieht richtig, wie die Städte atmen.
Genau, oder wie einfach die kleinsten Bewegungen sehr genau vermessen.
Das ist ja eigentlich für viele Bereiche interessant. Das habe ich gerade gehört, in Chile gibt es so ein Vulkangebiet, wo sich über einen längeren Zeitraum etwas angehoben hat. Auch so etwas lässt sich damit natürlich gut beobachten.
Im Prinzip bräuchten wir so ein System, um diese Prozesse auch besser zu verstehen. Unsere Wellenlänge hat da einen kleinen Nachteil. Und zwar müssen wir sicherstellen, dass nach elf Tagen die Szene sich nicht, oder das Gebiet sich nicht verändert hat. Wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt, man hat hier Vegetation und man hat Blätter, die sind natürlich nach elf Tagen nicht mehr in der gleichen Position. Und das X-Band reagiert aber genau auf die obersten Schichten der Vegetation. Das heißt, ich müsste eigentlich zu einer größeren Wellenlänge gehen, zum L-Band. Da sehe ich die stabilen Strukturen, da sehe ich die Äste und die Stämme der Bäume, den Grund drunter, den Boden, den festen Boden.
Dann nimmst du sozusagen das Höhenrauschen heraus.
Genau, ich nehme da das Vegetationsvolumen weg und kann damit dann wirklich den festen Boden sehen und dann solche Bewegungen global erfassen. Das wäre sehr wichtig, um Prozesse, gerade im Vulkanismus oder auch seismische Bewegungen, besser zu verstehen. Und sicher eine Voraussetzung, um vielleicht in der Zukunft hier so etwas wie Vorhersage oder in die Richtung entwickeln zu können.
Wir hatten ja hier bei Raumzeit auch schon eine Ausgabe, ganz zu Beginn, die sechste Ausgabe mit Hans-Joachim Lotz-Iven hier vom Erdbeobachtungsinstitut auf demselben Gelände, wo wir uns um Erdbeobachtung im Allgemeinen unterhalten haben. Da kam auch schon TanDEM-X zur Sprache. Und natürlich auch eine Vielzahl von Auswertungsmöglichkeiten und natürlich auch die ganzen Bedarfe für Erdbeobachtung. Die Gründe, warum man Erdbeobachtung macht, sind eigentlich relativ klar und wachsen. Wenn ich höre, dass jetzt um die 15 Satelliten mit der Technik allein schon unterwegs sind, dann ist das ja auch den gestiegenen Interesse der Umweltbeobachtung geschuldet. Was war denn dann jetzt bei dem TanDEM-X Projekt und vielleicht erst mal mit dieser Namenskonfusion, die da schnell auskam, erst mal reden, was war sozusagen der eigentliche Grund, dass jetzt diese Mission gestartet wurde und wie heißt diese Mission denn jetzt eigentlich genau?
Gut, es gibt ein Projekt TerraSAR-X, das entstand irgendwie 2001, 2002. Das war eben der einfache RADAR-Satellit, der eben die Erde abbildet, der Auflösungen in diesem 1-Meter-Bereich erzielen kann und in verschiedenen Moden hier die Erde abbildeten Produkte liefert. In der Frühphase entstand dann die Idee, diesen Satelliten um einen zweiten Satelliten zu ergänzen, den sogenannten TanDEM-X-Satelliten. TanDEM-X steht ja für TerraSAR-X add-on for digital elevation measurements, also das etwas draufsetzen auf TerraSAR, ein add-on, um digitale Höhenmodelle zu bestimmen. Dafür steht TanDEM-X.
Aber ich meine, man kann auch mit einem noch schon die Höhe messen.
Man kann die Höhe, wie ich gesagt habe, nur über stabilen, also in Städten, wo ich stabile Streue habe, da kann ich diese Technik anwenden. Aber sie funktioniert jetzt nicht global über allen möglichen Oberflächen.
Das heißt, am Anfang war eigentlich erst mal nur, stand nur zur Diskussion, überhaupt erst mal so ein SAR-Satelliten zur Erdbeobachtung zu haben und X heißt er, weil er im X-Band arbeitet. Und dann kam irgendjemand drauf, wie wär's denn, wenn wir uns noch einen zweiten dazu nehmen? Und der zweite Satellit führt dann dazu, dass man in kombinierter Beobachtung sich nicht mehr von dem Gebüsch ablenken lässt, obwohl man mit dem X-Band arbeitet, was da eigentlich so anfällig ist.
Genau, richtig. Und dann sind wir eigentlich bei dieser dritten Spielart. Wir hatten vorher gesagt, wir haben die einfachen Radarbilder. Wir können die kombinieren mit gewisser zeitlicher Verzögerung. Aber wenn wir das möglichst gleichzeitig machen, und darum fliegen die auch so eng beieinander, nebeneinander her, wenn wir das gleichzeitig machen, dann sehen wir die Objekte auch wirklich exakt unter gleichen Bedingungen und können eben diese Höhenmodelle auf der global erzeugen.
Also die Abkürzung ist ja sozusagen der Vater des Gedankens. Man denkt sich erst eine Abkürzung aus und danach überlegt man, wie es passen könnte, dass es dann heißt.
Ich glaube, es ist ungekehrt gelaufen. Ja, dann ist es natürlich jetzt noch ein bisschen verwirrend. Also wir haben jetzt hier zwei Satelliten, einer heißt TerraSAR-X, der andere ist TanDEM-X, aber wir haben auch zwei Missionen. Es gibt verknüpft mit dem ursprünglichen, nur mit dem einen TerraSAR-X-Satelliten die TerraSAR-X-Mission, die eben diese einzelnen Bilder erzeugt. Mittlerweile mit dem zweiten Satellit wird die TerraSAR-X-Mission von beiden Satelliten bedient. Also beide liefern Einzelaufnahmen. Wenn wir sie aber gemeinsam betreiben, gemeinsam nutzen, um im Interferometrie, also diese stereoähnliche Aufnahme zu machen, dann sind wir bei der TanDEM-X-Mission. Das heißt, wir haben zwei Satelliten. Wir im Projekt haben uns auch damit geholfen, wir haben für die Satelliten dann Abkürzungen eingeführt. Wir nennen den einen TSX und den anderen TDX. Und wenn wir von der Mission sprechen, weil wir hatten die gleiche Verwirrung, dann schreiben wir es aus und sagen, wir haben die TerraSAR-X-Mission und die TanDEM-X-Mission.
Okay, alles klar. Also, es gibt zwei Satelliten. Beide können separat arbeiten und liefern einfache Radarbilder in dieser SAR-Technik. Und das Ganze ist die TerraSAR-X-Mission. Man schaut halt einfach mit Radar auf die Erde. Und dann gibt es aber diesen speziellen Auswertungsmodus, der jetzt an den Satelliten so nichts ändert, sondern sie einfach gleichzeitig auf einen Ort schauen lässt und das ist dann eine andere wissenschaftliche Auswertung. Und das nennt sich TanDEM-X.
Ja, also, dass wir nichts ändern, stimmt nicht ganz. Wir mussten natürlich einiges ändern. Wir mussten sogar am TerraSAR weiter fortgeschritten in der Entwicklung. Mussten wir noch Änderungen einbauen. Zum Beispiel wurden kleine Antennen auf dem TerraSAR installiert, die es uns erlauben, Signale zwischen den zwei Satelliten auszutauschen. Das ist notwendig, weil wir müssen die beiden Radarsysteme miteinander synchronisieren.
Wir müssen, glaube ich, an dieser Stelle noch mal etwas genauer erläutern, was wir in gewisser Hinsicht nämlich jetzt voraussetzen, beziehungsweise nur sehr unzureichend angesprochen haben. Diese beiden Satelliten fliegen nebeneinander her. Über die Pole haben sie quasi eine fast identische Bahn, aber eben nicht ganz identisch, weil dann wären sie ja beide am selben Ort. Und sie können ja auch nicht die ganze Zeit nebeneinander herfliegen, weil am Pole würde es ja dann irgendwie knallen oder sonst irgendwo. Also es muss irgendwie geregelt werden. Also man hat zwei eng beieinander liegende Ringe um die Erde, die als Flugbahn dienen für diese beiden Objekte. Und irgendwie muss sich das ja auch steuern lassen. Also was ist jetzt erstmal die Motivation? Wie eng ist diese Bahn und was ist jetzt quasi Motivation und Notwendigkeit, sie so fliegen zu lassen, um zu den gewünschten Ergebnissen zu kommen?
Also wir fliegen zwischen 150 Meter, das war der geringste Abstand, den hatten wir in den letzten drei Monaten.
150 Meter?
Ja.
Auf welcher Höhe?
Auf 514 Kilometer.
Das ist ja nix.
Bei einer Geschwindigkeit von 28.000 Kilometer pro Stunde.
Das ist sehr wenig. Und im Moment haben wir es jetzt wieder vergrößert. Wir verändern diesen Abstand auf Laufend, das ist notwendig, um ein Höhenmodell, ein globales Höhenmodell in gleichmäßiger Genauigkeit und gleichmäßiger Qualität erzeugen zu können.
Aber fliegen die auch exakt auf derselben Höhe?
Nein, das tun sie nicht. Wir machen Folgendes. Den TerraSAR haben wir nicht verändert. Der fliegt nach wie vor auf seinem festen Orbit. Der wird nicht verändert. Der wird zwar immer wieder nachgeregelt. Wir halten diese Bahn sehr genau ein, sehr stabil. Wir müssen auch immer wieder nachsteuern. Selbst in dieser Höhe hat man eine gewisse Abbremsung. Der muss man entgegenwirken. Und den TanDEM-X hat man, um es mal zu erklären, in den gleichen Orbit gebracht. Aber man hat ihn am Äquator, wo die Bahnen, wo der Orbit nach oben läuft, horizontal getrennt. Wenn ich nur diese horizontale Trennung mache, dann habe ich genau das, was du vorhin angesprochen hast. Die würden sich über den Polen natürlich kreuzen. Wir hätten hier natürlich ein massives Kollisionsrisiko. D.h., ich muss noch eine zweite Maßnahme treffen. Es reicht nicht nur, die zu trennen, weil dann würden sich die jeweils am Nord- oder Südpol treffen.
Das sei denn, der eine läuft gleich hinterher.
Ja, aber das wollen wir ja nicht. Wir wollen ja möglichst gleichzeitig auf die Erde schauen. Das brauchen wir eben für die Interferometrie, damit die Blätter wirklich noch an der Position sind, wie es ja auch der andere gesehen hat. Und die zweite Maßnahme ist die folgende. Die Orbits sind immer leicht elliptisch. Und der TerraSAR ist ein sogenannter stabiler Orbit. In der Höhe gibt es genau eine Orbit-Konstellation, eine Konstellation von Parametern, die einigermaßen stabil ist. Beim TanDEM machen wir jetzt folgendes. Wir ändern diese Ellipse leicht. Wir ändern die Exzentrizität der Ellipse.
Boilt sich mehr aus?
Genau, die wird auf der einen Seite über dem Nordpol ein bisschen weiter rausgeboilt. Und über dem Südpol ist sie ein bisschen näher dran an der Erdoberfläche. Das heißt, die sind so gegeneinander verschoben. Und jetzt haben wir folgenden Effekt. Wir haben über den Polen eine vertikale Trennung. Und zwar einmal ist der TanDEM über dem TerraSAR und auf der anderen Seite ist es genau andersrum. Und wenn man sich das jetzt vorstellt, wenn man jetzt hinterher fliegt, dann habe ich am Äquator die Seitwärtstrennung horizontal.
Aber da sind sie dann auch wirklich auf der gleichen Höhe.
Da sind sie auf der gleichen Höhe, kurz. Und dann geht der TanDEM langsam höher, fliegt über dem TerraSAR hinweg. Auf der anderen Seite am Äquator sind sie wieder seitlich versetzt, aber der TanDEM ist jetzt da nicht rechts, sondern links, sage ich jetzt mal, auf dem TerraSAR, wenn man in die Flugrichtung schaut. Und auf dem Südpol ist es umgekehrt. Da taucht quasi der TanDEM unter dem TerraSAR durch. Also wir schrauben, der TanDEM schraubt sich so einmal um den TerraSAR rum.
Das heißt, der TanDEM muss auch mehr von dieser Ideallinie abweichen, muss auch mehr gesteuert werden.
Genau, und muss deshalb auch laufend, um diese Konstellation stabil zu halten, muss auch laufend gesteuert werden.
Das heißt, er hat auch mehr Treibstoff an Bord als das Erste?
Er hat nicht nur mehr Treibstoff, er hat zusätzlich, er hat eigentlich vom Hydrazin, das ist unser wesentlicher Treibstoff, hat er die gleiche Menge, aber er hat ein zusätzliches Antriebssystem drauf. Weil diese Hydrazintriebwerke, die können einen gewissen Schub, das ist ungefähr einen Newton, erzeugen, aber um diese feine Änderung, um diese sogenannte, wir nennen es die Helix, weil es erinnert so ein bisschen an die Doppelhelix von der DNA. Um diese Helix zu steuern, brauche ich viel feinere Impulse und dafür haben wir ein sogenanntes Kaltgassystem. Das ist einfach ein großer Tank mit Stickstoff und sehr hohem Druck, 250 bar. Wir haben da irgendwie knapp 40 Kilo Stickstoff an Bord. Der Stickstoff wird einfach durch kleine Düsen abgelassen. Und das gibt jetzt im Vergleich zu den einen Newton vom Hydrazin, gibt es irgendwie 40 Millineutenschub, also einen deutlich kleineren Schub. Was sind das? 400 Zelt Newton Schub.
Das reicht, um diesen kleinen Schwung dann zu machen.
Und damit müssen wir solche Manöver machen, täglich, und zwar müssen wir immer eins in Flug und eins gegen die Flugrichtung machen, um diese verschobene Ellipse aufrecht halten zu können.
Wie weit sind die denn dann in der Höhe auseinander am Pol?
Ja, das sind auch so diese 200, 300 Meter.
Okay, verstehe.
Das ändern wir auch, das passen wir auch an.
Das heißt, der relative Abstand dieser beiden Objekte ist mehr oder weniger konstant, nur drückt er sich am Äquator quasi in der Breite und ging Pol in der Höhe aus.
Genau, genau.
Das ist also so ein Möbiusband, was die beiden da eigentlich um die Erde herum weben.
Also wenn man den TerraSAR festhält, dann bewegt sich der TanDEM auf einer Ellipse um den TerraSAR und die ist noch gegenüber der Orbit-Bahn vom TerraSAR verkippt.
Sehr hübsch. Tja, da muss man erstmal drauf kommen. Ist das schon so ein lang gehegter Traum der Raumfahrer oder ist das wirklich so eine ganz neue Idee?
Das ist auch eine neue Idee, die auch patentiert wurde von meinen DLR-Kollegen.
Das heißt, die beiden sind auch nicht identisch, aber im Wesentlichen tun sie schon dasselbe. Die Steuerung ist anders, aber jetzt von der Radartechnik her machen die nichts anderes. Ganz im Gegenteil, sie müssen sogar relativ ähnlich sein, damit man die Bilder auch entsprechend auswählen kann.
Genau, es ist sogar so, weil wir ja für die TerraSAR-Missionen Bilder von beiden Satelliten liefern, da ist es ganz wichtig, dass sie die gleiche Qualität liefern. Der Endnutzer soll nicht erkennen, von welchem Satelliten das Bild kommt. Die sind auch sehr gute Kopien. Wir haben von perfekten Zwillingen gesprochen.
Sind die denn auch beide gleichzeitig gestartet worden?
Nein, wie gesagt, die Idee für den zweiten ist erst erst entstanden. Da war das Projekt vom ersten schon ein, zwei Jahre unterwegs. Die zwei Missionen sind auch programmatisch sehr interessant. Weil man hat eine Mission, ein Projekt auf den Weg gebracht, TerraSAR-X. Und dann ist noch ein zweites Parallel dazu entstanden, das mit dem ersten sehr eng verknüpft ist. Aber es ist in der Zeitschiene verschoben. Und der TerraSAR ist ja dann im Juni 2007 gestartet, also mittlerweile fast fünf Jahre im Orbit. Und der TanDEM-X kam vor zwei Jahren dann im Juni 2010 nach.
Man weiß ja, in der Raumfahrt die Dinge brauchen eine lange Planung. Und überhaupt ein Projekt durchzubekommen, Ideen gibt es ja ohne Ende. Bedarf es natürlich aller möglichen Absprachen, politische Wunschrichtungen, Gelder müssen vorhanden sein etc. Wenn da jetzt so eine Gruppe kommt, die schon so ihr Projekt hat und sagt, es macht gerade so einen Spaß, wir hätten jetzt eigentlich ganz gerne noch einen zweiten, dann klingt das ja erstmal nicht unbedingt so nach etwas, wo dann alle gleich die Hände heben und sagen, wo ihr gerade so viel Spaß habt, dann nehmt doch noch einfach einen dazu. Ich meine, da musste man ja dann auch wirklich ein extrem überzeugendes, wissenschaftliches Argument bringen, um so etwas dann auch noch auf die Spur zu kriegen.
Ja, ich sag mal, das war sicher keine einfache Situation. Aber das Konzept war schon sehr überzeugend. Und wir haben ja mittlerweile die Bestätigung, es funktionierte auch sehr gut. Und wir haben natürlich mit dem digitalen Höhenmodell ein einmaliges Produkt, das wissenschaftlich interessant ist, das kommerziell ein sehr hohes Potential hat. Wir haben natürlich technologisch einen Riesensprung gemacht. Wir sind im Moment weltweit sicher führend. Das macht keine andere Nation. Macht solche Radartechnik wie wir mit TanDEM-X. Und vielleicht zu diesem wissenschaftlichen und kommerziellen, dazu noch zu sagen, dass natürlich die beiden Missionen ein Public-Private-Partnership implementiert wurden. Der Public Partner ist eben das DLR. Private ist die Firma Astrium in Friedrichshafen am Bodensee. Die haben die Satelliten beigestellt. Und die Astrium Services sind auch für die Vermarktung sowohl der Einzelbilder als auch der Höhenmodelle verantwortlich, während das DLR die Wissenschaftler bedient. Und diese Gesamtkonstellation, die war natürlich ausschlaggebend, hier wirklich den zweiten Schritt zu tun. Und das ist ganz richtig, das ist eine sehr einmalige Situation. Wir sind hier nicht allein, wir waren auch nicht allein mit unserem Vorschlag. Es gab andere Vorschläge. Und das gab letztendlich doch den Ausschlag, diesen Weg zu gehen.
Welche, also vielleicht mal auch so ein bisschen in Zahlen, was bringt quasi der zweite Satellit mit rein? Also einerseits eliminiert er erstmal quasi eine Störung. Also man kann etwas überhaupt erst machen, nämlich ein extrem genaues Höhenmodell der Erde zu liefern. Obwohl man eben diese hohe Frequenz verwendet, die das eigentlich so nicht kann, oder zumindest nur in Bereichen kann, wo eben kein Buschwerk ist. Also ich meine, in Vulkan hätte man wahrscheinlich noch ausgemessen bekommen, aber eben nicht, wenn da ein Wald drauf ist. Wie genau sind diese Messergebnisse? Was kann gemessen werden?
Ja, wir messen wieder mit der Interferometrie. Also ich habe im Prinzip zwei Radelsysteme an unterschiedlichen Positionen. Und was wir messen, ist der Entfernungsunterschied zu einem Punkt auf der Erdauervläche zwischen den beiden. Und den messen wir sehr genau, und zwar wieder über eine Phasenmessung. Und da muss man sich jetzt vor Augen halten, unsere Wellendänge ist 3 cm. Das entspricht einem kompletten Phasenzyklus, also einem Umlauf 360°. Wir können die Phase aber in der Größenordnung 10° genau bestimmen. Das heißt, was bedeutet das für die Entfernung? Wir können den Entfernungsunterschied auf 1 mm genau bestimmen. Und das jetzt kombiniert mit einer sehr genauen Kenntnis einerseits des Orbits. Also wir kennen den einzelnen Orbit vom Satelliten auf wenige Zentimeter genau. Und noch einer noch genaueren Kenntnis des Abstands zwischen beiden. Den messen wir mit GPS. Wir haben auf beiden Satelliten ein Zweifrequenz-GPS-System. Und aus diesen GPS-Daten können wir den Abstand ebenfalls millimetergenau bestimmen.
Also den Abstand der beiden Satelliten untereinander.
Wenn wir das alles zusammennehmen, können wir Höhenmodelle, können wir ein globales Höhenmodell erzeugen, das absolut besser als 10 Meter genau sein wird. Also jeder einzelne Höhenpunkt wird absolut besser als 10 Meter genau bekannt sein. In einem Raster von 12 mal 12 Meter, also wichtig ist, wir liefern Höhenwerte auf 12 mal 12 Meter. Und wir haben noch einen weiteren Parameter, das ist die sogenannte relative Höhengenauigkeit, die so definiert, wenn man sich ein Gebiet vorstellt, von 1 Grad Länge mal 1 Grad Breite, geografische Länge Breite. Das sind etwa 100 mal 100 Kilometer am Äquator. Dann darf der Höhenfehler zwischen zwei beliebigen Punkten in diesem Gebiet, der darf nicht größer als 2 Meter sein.
Also wenn man sich zwei Punkte in diesem Quadrat anschaut, dann ist der Unterschied sehr genau. Warum jetzt auf einmal 10 Meter? Vorhin haben wir doch davon gesprochen, dass man irgendwie Millimeterbewegungen messen kann.
Ja, das war für diese andere Technik. Das war diese eine Spielart, wo ich einfach das wiederhole, wo ich möglichst an der gleichen Position bin. Wo man durch die Repetition die Genauigkeit erzielt. Da kann ich die Höhe gar nicht so genau bestimmen. Da kann ich eigentlich gar keine Höhe messen, von der gleichen Position aus. Ich brauche ja Trennung, ich brauche, wie beim Stereo, ich brauche irgendwie zwei Augen, die getrennt sind.
Aber keinen Unterschied über die Zeit kann man genauer messen. Aber absolut gesehen reicht es gerade mal für 10 Meter Höhe. Das klingt ja jetzt eigentlich nicht so auflösend, 10 Meter. Was wusste man denn bisher?
Ja, bisher haben wir global gesehen, haben wir sehr schlechte Informationen, speziell die Polkappen. Da gibt es Höheninformationen nur in einem 1 Kilometer Raster. Und dann gab es eben diese Shuttle-Räder-Topography-Mission, SRTM, im Jahr 2000. Und da wurde der Bereich zwischen plus, minus 60 Grad, also der Space Shuttle kann keinen polaren Orbit fliegen, daher konnte man nur den Bereich abdecken. Und da gibt es Daten auf 30 mal 30 Meter, die sind aber nicht alle frei verfügbar. Und die absolute Höhengenauigkeit ist irgendwo bei 18 Meter und relativ, bin ich jetzt nicht ganz sicher, glaube ich, bei 10 oder 12 Meter. Also wir haben schon eine deutliche Verbesserung hier in allen Dimensionen, sowohl was die Rasterung betrifft, als auch die absolute und relative Höhengenauigkeit. Speziell die relative Höhengenauigkeit ist auch ein wichtiger Treiber für die Mission.
Ja, die absolute Höhe bezieht sich dann auf welchen, also auf den Meeresspiegel als Referenz?
In unserem Fall beziehen wir uns auf den Ellipsoid, das WGS 84, also ein Referenz-Ellipsoid.
Das war auch GPS benutzt. Okay, 10 Meter. Ich meine, das ist jetzt so eine theoretische Fehlergröße.
Das ist im Prinzip die Anforderung, das müssen wir erreichen. Wir sind eigentlich sehr zuversichtlich, dass wir das deutlich übertreffen können, gerade die absolute Höhengenauigkeit.
Das weiß man aber noch nicht.
Das wissen wir natürlich erst. Das Aufnahmeszenario schaut ja befolgt aus. Im zweiten Halbjahr 2010 haben wir das System in Betrieb genommen. Wir haben jetzt ein Jahr lang die Erde aufgenommen. Wir brauchen ein Jahr, um eine globale Abdeckung herzustellen, um einmal die gesamte Landmasse aufzunehmen. Um auf diese Genauigkeit zu kommen, müssen wir das aber zweistufig anwenden. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt mal mit etwas kleinerer Basislinie, das ist in der Ferrometer nicht so genau, eine Basis gelegt, eine erste Höhenkarte erzeugt. Und legen jetzt eine zweite drauf mit etwas größer. Wir müssen da in zwei Stufen arbeiten, sonst können wir das nicht robust prozessieren. Dann hätten wir Probleme hier in der Verarbeitung der Daten. Das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt ein weiteres Jahr für eine zweite Aufnahme. Und wir haben dann noch gewisse schwierige Gebiete, Gebirge, da ist noch am Eingangsgesetz nicht erwähnt. Das Radar ist ja ein Seitensichtgerät, das heißt, wir schauen immer zur Seite. Beleuchten wir oder beobachten wir einen Streifen. Und wenn man sich jetzt hier einen Gebirge vorstellt, einen Berg, dann gibt es natürlich jetzt einen Bereich, der ist im Schatten. Also ich sehe die abweisende Flanke vom Berg nicht. Und dafür brauchen wir dann noch im nächsten Jahr einige Monate. Da werden wir die Konstellation umbauen oder die Formation umbauen, sodass wir diese Gebiete von der anderen Seite beobachten können.
Warum muss man von der Seite gucken? Warum guckt man nicht einfach von oben? Es geht doch darum, eine Reflexion zu bekommen.
Das hat damit zu tun, dass wir über die Auflösung gesprochen haben, mit der langen Antenne, das betritt sich aber nur auf die Flugrichtung. Für die zweite Dimension, also für die Entfernungsrichtung, benutzen wir Pulsmodulation. Wir senden modulierte Pulse aus, machen dann Pulskompressionen und kommen da auch wieder auf den Einmeter Auflösung. Aber wenn man jetzt direkt gerade nach unten schaut, dann hätte ich hier einen sehr großen Fleck. Erst durch die Seitensicht ergibt sich das. Das sind so Kugelschalen, die sich mit der Erdoberfläche schneiden. Die Welle wird von der Antenne ausgesendet. Ich kriege hier meine äquidistanten Punkte, die in der gleichen Entfernung sind. Wenn ich direkt nach unten schaue, hätte ich hier einen riesigen Fleck und eine sehr schlechte Auflösung. Erst durch die Seitensicht, je flacher ich schaue, umso besser wird eigentlich diese Entfernungsauflösung. Daher müssen wir zur Seite schauen.
Warum dauert das ein Jahr? Beide fliegen ihre Ellipsen an der selben Stelle, darunter dreht sich die Erde quasi um sich herum. Dann ist nach 24 Stunden alles mal angeguckt worden.
Nein, so reintäugig ist das nicht. Das dachte ich mir schon. Wir fliegen diesen Elftage-Wiederholzyklus. Das heißt, in elf Tagen macht der Satellit 167 Robits. Das kann man sich jetzt als Bodenspur auf die Erde legen. Diese Spur hätte jetzt am Äquator einen Abstand von 250 Kilometer, 40.000 durch 167 Kilometer in der Richtung. Unsere Streifenbreite, die wir aufnehmen können, ist nur 30 Kilometer. Um am Äquator das abdecken zu können, brauche ich schon 10 Streifen. Das ist da schon nicht möglich. Zusätzlich ist die Einschaltzeit des Satelliten primär aus energetischen und thermalen Gründen beschränkt. Einerseits wird diese Antenne sehr warm. Die würde dann zu warm werden. Da können wir jetzt nicht zu lange einschalten.
Durch den Betrieb selbst?
Durch den Betrieb selbst. Wir senden ja auch das Radar. Das ist ja wichtig. Das Radar ist unabhängig von Tag und Nacht. Wir brauchen keine Sonne, keine Beleuchtung. Wir schicken ja Signale aus. Wir senden Signale aus und empfangen die Reflexion. Aber die Signale muss man erzeugen. Dafür braucht man richtig Energie. Dafür haben die Satelliten auch ein Solarpaneel dran. Die ist auch immer der Sonne zugewandt. Aber der Energieeintrag ist natürlich hier beschränkt. Wir können größtenordnungsmäßig 3-4 Minuten pro Orbit operieren. Von fast 100 Minuten Orbit. Und wenn man das alles zusammen nimmt, dann dauert es ein Jahr.
Okay, verstehe. Das heißt, er kann auch nur funktionieren, wenn er gerade die Sonne sieht?
Das stimmt nicht. Er hat schon Batterien, die auch geladen werden. Da muss man jetzt dazu sagen, der Orbit, den wir fliegen, fliegt an der Tag-Nacht-Grenze entlang. Das heißt eigentlich, unser Orbit bewegt sich quasi damit. Die Orbit-Bahn ist immer in der Sonne. Die Orbit-Ebene. Das Problem ist nur, dass wir uns natürlich mit der Erde mitbewegen. Das hat einen Effekt, dass wir im Sommer kurzzeitig über der Südhalbkugel im Erdschatten sind. Weil die Erde in die Erdachse gedreht ist, geneigt ist, und die 23 Grad ergeben sich dann hier im Sommer für 3-4 Monate. Dann dreht man langsam ein in den Erdschatten, wird das immer länger. Ich glaube, das ist im Maximum ungefähr 20 Minuten im Erdschatten.
Also im Sommer gibt es ja zwei Mal im Jahr sozusagen.
Unser Nordhalbkugelsommer.
Ok, ein Jahr lang. Und was für Daten, also es wird ausschließlich eine Höhenmessung vorgenommen?
Ja, die primäre Messung, die wir machen, sind zwei Radaraufnahmen. Wir haben natürlich auch, das ist so ein Nebenprodukt kann man sagen, ein interessantes, wir haben eine globale Radar-Karte. Wir haben natürlich die gesamte Erdoberfläche, die Landmassen, haben wir wirklich als Radaraufnahme auch vorliegen im X-Band. Das ist auch ein sehr interessanter Datensatz. Und wir brauchen diese Information einerseits sogar, um unser System noch besser einstellen zu können, weil wir wissen, wenn wir vorab schon wissen, wie gut die Reflexion der Oberfläche ist, können wir unser Radargerät besser adjustieren, können hier besser die Parameter einstellen. Das ist aber natürlich auch ein hochinteressanter Datensatz, der sicher auch noch in die eine oder andere Richtung ausgewertet wird. Zum Beispiel entsteht hier so was wie ein Global Urban Footprint. Man versucht, die urbanen Gebiete global zu kartieren.
Um überhaupt erst mal zu wissen, wo überhaupt die Stadt ist.
Ja, da gibt es ja die Megacities, die mehr oder weniger kontrolliert wuchern und wie sich die auch verändern.
Und das kann man dem Radar direkt ansehen?
Das kann man aus dem Radar gut ablesen, weil im Prinzip alles, was man-made, also von Menschenhand gebaut wird, üblicherweise deutlich mehr Reflexion zeigt als die Vegetation oder die sonstigen Oberflächen.
Was war denn dann das eigentliche Ziel der TerraSAR-X-Mission? Also die nur mit dem einen Satelliten startet, wenn man da jetzt keine detaillierten Höheninformationen bekommt. Was hat man sich von den Radarbildern versprochen?
Ja, da gibt es auch verschiedenste Anwendungsgebiete. Da gibt es einerseits einen großen Bereich, auch diese Landnutzung, die wir gerade auch angesprochen haben. Da gibt es auch noch verschiedene Moden, da kann man auch noch genauer unterscheiden. Man kann zum Beispiel unterschiedliche Bewuchs, also unterschiedliche Getreidearten unterscheiden, wenn man das auch dann über die Vegetationszeit hinweg verfolgt. Das ist so ein Bereich, das ist natürlich auch ein Bereich im Maritin-Bereich. Man kann Schiffe detektieren, man kann da im Schiffsverkehr überwachen. Wir können zum Beispiel sehr gut Ölverschmutzung detektieren, weil dadurch die Wasseroberfläche geklettet wird durch einen Ölfilm und das Radarsignal dann wegreflektiert wird. Die erscheinen dann sehr dunkel. Also Katastrophenhilfe ist ein wichtiges Thema. Wir betreiben ja hier das Zentrum für satellitengestützte Kriseninformation. Und für die ist TerraSAR eine ganz wichtige Quelle, weil er ihm zuverlässig Daten liefert. Und dann hat man zum Beispiel Schadenskartierung gemacht beim Tsunamidesaster in Japan oder man hat die Ölkatastrophe im Golf von Mexiko verfolgt.
Ja, da hatten wir auch hier schon eine Sendung bei Raumzeit. Da muss ich gleich drauf verweisen. Ausgabe 25, Zentrum für Kriseninformationen. Wollte ich auch noch erwähnen, dass das eine von den Sendungen war, die das TanDEM-X-Projekt schon genannt haben. ZKI, Raumzeit 25 mit Tobias Schneiderhahn. Auf der einen Seite dauert es ein Jahr, bis man die Welt kategografiert. Auf der anderen Seite soll man Schiffe verfolgen. Das heißt, wann der Satellit aktiviert wird, das ist kurzfristig zu bestimmen. Man weiß, innerhalb von spätestens elf Tagen kann man eigentlich jeden Bereich der Erde mal überfliegen. Das ist sozusagen das Maximum, solange kann es dauern. Aber dann ist man schon in der Lage zu sagen, jetzt wollen wir uns das aber auch wirklich mal genau anschauen.
Für die TerraSAR-Mission ist das genauso. Ich habe im Prinzip meinen Elftagezyklus. Ich weiß, welches Gebiet ich zu welcher Zeit beobachten kann. Wenn ich jetzt weiter nach Norden gehe auf der Erde, dann treffen sich die Bahnen, dann habe ich mehr Möglichkeiten, dann kann ich öfter ein bestimmtes Gebiet beobachten. Genau wie du beschrieben hast, wird hier kurzzeitig entschieden. Oder man macht quasi einen Plan für einzelne Aufnahmen. Eine spezielle Herausforderung für die zwei Missionen war, dass wir aber mit der TanDEM-X-Mission globale Abdeckung erreichen wollen. Das heißt, wir müssen sicherstellen, dass wir in dem einen Jahr die ganzen Landmaßen abdecken. Und das miteinander zu verknüpfen, das war eine spezielle Herausforderung. Wir haben das so gelöst, dass wir im Prinzip diese globale Abdeckung planen, wie im Voraus. Die wird mit hoher Priorität eingestellt in unsere Timeline. Die Lücken, die dann bleiben, die nutzt man dann für die TerraSAR-Mission und den Spielraum.
Das heißt, wenn es jetzt eine Anfrage gäbe vom ZKI, einen Bereich zu beobachten, der in Konflikt steht mit der festgeplanten, dann müsste man das verschieben?
Man könnte, also es gibt in diesem globalen Aufnahmeplan eine gewisse Flexibilität, die kann man dann nutzen, aber nur bis zum bestimmten Grad, weil das hängt auch zusammen. Wir ändern auch diese Helix-Formation laufend und wir können dann dieses Gebiet nicht mehr mit der idealen Formation aufnehmen. Das heißt, es ist nur über einige Rapidzyklen hinweg möglich. Und die kann man schon verschieben. Es ist auch vorgesehen, dass sehr hochprioritäre TerraSAR-Aufnahmen eine TanDEM-Aufnahme verdrängen. Und da wird versucht, die möglichst bald wieder neu einzuplanen. Also der Mechanismus ist schon da, um eben in solchen Fällen wie einer Katastrophe doch reagieren zu können.
Man muss halt abwägen, was möglich ist und was nicht möglich ist.
Wir wollten natürlich, für uns ist es nicht wichtig, das primäre Ziel ist, auch ein globales Höhenmodell zu erzeugen. Also es sollen ja keine Lippen drin sein. Oder die möglichst zu minimieren.
Klang ja anfangs schon an. Einerseits Public-Private-Partnership, auf der anderen Seite hohes kommerzielles Potenzial auch in diesen Daten. Wofür werden denn diese Daten sonst noch genutzt, außer jetzt zur Umweltbeobachtung? Also was ist so das kommerzielle Interesse?
Im kommerziellen Bereich ist sicher ein großes Thema der Sicherheitsbereich, sicherheitsrelevante Anwendungen, militärische Anwendungen und Nutzer, die sowohl auf die hochaufgelösten Bilder zugreifen, als auch natürlich Interesse an den Höhenmodellen haben. Im kommerziellen Bereich ist aber auch ein wichtiges Thema topografische Kartierung und hier eben die hochgenaue Höheninformation zu nutzen, um eben topografische Karten zu erzeugen in Gebieten außerhalb der Industrienationen, wo eigentlich schon recht kartiert ist.
Ich lasse eine Frage nicht los. Also diese Genauigkeit dieser Höheninformationen. Auf der einen Seite hat man jetzt erst mal prinzipbedingt so 10 Meter Genauigkeit. Das heißt ja nicht, dass man um 10 Meter daneben liegt. Oder? Das ist richtig verstanden, man nimmt das immer wieder auf. Man hat permanent Vergleichsmöglichkeiten. Man hat auch durch GPS und andere Messungen und man weiß ja einfach von bestimmten Orten, wie hoch sie sind, müsste man doch eigentlich so viel Referenz- und Vergleichsmaterial haben, dass man dann mindestens über die Zeit diese ganzen Messungen noch auf eine ganz andere Genauigkeit heben könnte, oder?
Ich muss noch mal einhaken bei den 10 Metern. Der Fehler hat natürlich eine gewisse Statistik, eine gewisse Verteilung und wenn wir hier von 10 Metern sprechen, dann reden wir hier nicht von der Standardabweichung, die man üblicherweise angibt im statistischen Fall, sondern wir reden von 90% aller Fehler. Also ein deutlich breiteres Intervall als die Standardabweichung. Das heißt, dass wirklich die Standardabweichung, das ist glaube ich ein Faktor 2,2 oder irgend sowas, ist deutlich enger, also wäre deutlich besser. Wir nutzen jetzt natürlich externe Höheninformation. Referenzdaten werden genutzt. Und zwar nutzen wir Daten von einem Laser-Alkimetersatelliten. Also das ist quasi ein Lasersystem der NASA, der hieß ICESAT. Der war eigentlich dazu da, die Polkappen zu kartieren. Und der hat einfach hier quasi senkrecht nach unten, nimmt einzelne Höhenpunkte auf. Und diese Höhenpunkte, die sind global verfügbar, die sind frei verfügbar, die nutzen wir, die sind in der Genauigkeit deutlich besser als ein Meter. Und die benutzen wir in einer Ausgleichsrechnung, weil unsere Aufnahmen werden in kleine Höhenmodelle verrechnet. So 30 mal 50 Kilometer. Und die werden dann alle zusammenkalibriert und ausgeglichen, wie wir es nennen. Und da benutzen wir dann als Referenz diese Eissaatinformation. Und was wir im Moment, drum habe ich vorher gesagt, wir sind zuversichtlich, dass wir die 10 Meter gut einhalten können, wir sind im Moment, wir sind noch nicht an diesem letzten Schritt. Den machen wir erst, wenn wir alle Daten gesammelt haben. Aber diese einzelnen kleinen Höhenmodelle, diese 30 mehr als 50 Kilometer Höhenmodelle, die sind schon recht genau. Und die erfüllen schon fast diese 10 Meter Anforderung. Das heißt, wir erwarten, dass wir eigentlich dann global mit dem finalen Modell doch deutlich besser sein werden.
Also was heißt das dann, ein paar Meter genau?
In der Größenordnung, genau.
Aber mit derselben Technologie jetzt irgendwann auch so eine Millimeterkartierung zu erreichen, das ist jetzt illusorisch?
Das ist im Moment so nicht möglich. Also für diese, was wir dann natürlich schon genau machen können, wir können Änderungen noch mal deutlich genauer fassen. Wir könnten natürlich, das System an sich, könnte noch mit deutlich größerem Abstand betrieben werden. Also wir könnten da auf ein, zwei Kilometer Entfernung gehen. Aber wir haben dann dieses Problem, also zwischen den beiden Satelliten, also nicht diese 200 bis 500 Meter, und würden noch mal deutlich genauer werden in der Höhe. Wir müssten aber das wieder in mehreren Schritten machen. Das können wir halt nicht in der Mission, die ja nur für drei Jahre angelegt ist, können wir das nicht leisten. Es gibt im Moment gute Hoffnung, dass die Satelliten, das sind eigentlich beide Satelliten, die sind für 5,5 Jahre gebaut, dafür sind sie eigentlich designt worden, haben aber Ressourcen, Treibstoff für bis zu sieben Jahre. Und im Moment sind wir guter Hoffnung und alle Daten vom Satelliten zeigen, dass wir mit deutlich mehr Lebensdauer rechnen können.
Also drei Jahre war sozusagen das angestrebte Minimum?
Das Minimum, um dieses globale Höhenmodell zu erreichen.
Einfach alles dreimal gemessen zu haben.
Wahrscheinlich werden wir die zwei bis drei Jahre länger betreiben können. Und dann ist ja ein sekundäres Missionsziel, ist ja auch wirklich noch genauere Höhenmodelle zu erzeugen. Aber dann halt lokal begrenzt. Dann wird man ein gewisses Gebiet mal angucken und das dann wirklich noch mal genauer erfassen.
Und das würde man dann sozusagen dadurch erreichen, dass man die beiden noch weiter voneinander entfernt?
Genau. Man braucht als Basis dieses globale Höhenmodell und kann darauf aufbauen, dann vielleicht in ein, zwei Schritten noch genauer werden.
Aber wenn jetzt ein größerer Abstand zwischen den beiden Satelliten ohnehin bessere Ergebnisse erzielt, warum macht man das nicht sowieso gleich?
Naja, das Problem ist, wir messen eben diesen Entfernungsunterschied über die Phasen. Und eine gewisse Höhenänderung, also zwischen zwei Punkten am Boden, ergibt oben quasi einen Phasenwert. Und wenn die Phase einmal rum ist, also einmal 360 Grad durchlaufen hat, dann kann ich den Phasenwert da nicht mehr unterscheiden. Das heißt, wir haben...
Also eine physikalische Grenze, wie man das auseinanderdrücken kann.
Genau. Und was wir jetzt ja sehen, oder wir arbeiten jetzt mit einer, wir nennen diese Höhe, die diese 360 Grad erzeugt, oder dieser 360 Grad Phasenänderung entspricht, die nennen wir die Height of Ambiguity. Weil dann bin ich eben, dann habe ich Ambiguous Phase.
Die Höhe der Doppeldeutigkeit sozusagen.
Doppeldeutigkeit, genau. Und die liegt bei uns in der Größenordnung 35, 40, 50 Meter. Wenn ich da jetzt deutlich drunter gehe und ich stelle mir ein Waldgebiet vor...
40, 50 Meter was? Höhe.
Ah, Höhe, genau. Wenn ich da jetzt auf 20, auf 10 Meter gehe und ich stelle mir vor, ich habe irgendwo ein Waldgebiet, so die Kante der Bäume, dann würde ich die nicht richtig erfassen. Weil das ist deutlich höher und ich würde quasi dann nur die halbe Höhe messen. Und um diesen Effekt in den Griff zu kriegen, machen wir das eben in Stufen.
Alles nicht so einfach. Also man merkt, das Projekt beschreitet an der Stelle sozusagen Neuland. Einerseits, was die Satellitensteuerung als solche betrifft, weil eben diese Bahn zu fliegen ist, insofern vorher noch nicht gemacht worden. Aber mit diesen hier gewonnenen Daten kann man auch erstmals mit Radar auf eine Art und Weise arbeiten, wie es so vorher auch noch nicht gemacht wurde. Das heißt, das Ganze ist an der Stelle gar nicht mal jetzt nur eine direkte wissenschaftliche Erkenntnis, sondern es ist eigentlich auch Grundlagenarbeit, die an der Stelle gemacht wird.
Genau, ganz richtig. Also speziell dieser gemeinsame Betrieb, wir nennen das bistatische Betrieb, weil nur einer sendet und empfängt die Reflexion, und der zweite ist nur ein Empfänger. Und die sind getrennt. Wenn die zwei räumlich getrennt sind, dann sprechen wir von Bi, also zwei Bi-Static. Und dieser Betrieb, die Synchronisation der beiden Radarsysteme, man muss sich so vorstellen, das Herzstück in jedem Radar ist eine hochgenaue Uhr. Jeder der zwei Radarinstrumente hat eine genaue Uhr. Sehr genaue Uhr. Aber die sind nie exakt identisch. Und wir müssen eben diesen kleinen Unterschied, den müssen wir erfassen, weil den müssen wir korrigieren. Sonst würde das dann Effekte haben, dass eben Berge entstehen, wo keine Berge sind.
Ja, einfach weil die Zeit nicht stimmt.
Genau, weil da eben die andere Phasen gemessen werden.
Und diese Korrektur, das wird auch dadurch gemacht, dass die beiden untereinander kommunizieren.
Genau, dass die untereinander…
Also im Wesentlichen die Zeit wird unter den beiden ausgearbeitet.
Ja, die tauschen richtig Pulse aus. Also wir machen Folgendes, üblicherweise senden wir einen Puls auf den Boden und fangen die Reflexion. Das unterbrechen wir kurz. Und die gleichen Pulse werden zwischen den zwei Satelliten hin und her geschickt und aufgezeichnet. An Bord wird da nichts irgendwie ausgewertet, sondern das landet im Datenstrom. Und die gesamte Auswertung und die Synchronisation passiert eigentlich dann später erst in der Verarbeitung.
Das heißt, diese Pulse zwischen den beiden Satelliten sind quasi der Basistakt, mit dem man dann die eigentliche Messung interpretiert. Oder zumindest einen Korrekturwert da in den ganzen Berechnungen.
Sie müssen natürlich auch zeitlich sehr genau abgestimmt sein, die zwei Satelliten, weil es funktioniert ja so, wir senden einen Puls und dann mit einer bestimmten Verzögerung öffnen wir erst das Empfangsfenster und empfangen Signale und tasten die ab. Wir können ja nicht gleichzeitig senden und abtasten. Der zweite ist aber nur Empfänger. Dessen Echo-Fenster muss mit dem ersten abgestimmt sein. Da reden wir von Mikrosekundengenauigkeit.
Und das programmiert man auch im Vornhinein, also man sagt, dann wird der eine senden, also musst du auch zuhören. Wenn die Zeit dann nicht stimmt, dann wird er ja gar nicht zum richtigen Zeitpunkt zuhören. Also es ist gar nicht mal nur für die Interpretation der Messwerte wichtig, die richtige Zeit zu haben, sondern dass es überhaupt welche gibt.
Genau, ganz richtig. Und dafür waren sogar noch Änderungen am Satelliten in der Software notwendig, damit die wirklich auch exakt gleichzeitig hier loslegen sozusagen. Die Gleichzeitigkeit ist wichtig. Klar, beide haben GPS, das gibt schon den Takt, das gibt so einen Sekundentakt, aber das muss ja dann runter auf die Mikrosekunde genau stimmen.
Was war nochmal die Höhe? 500 Kilometer? 514 Kilometer. Inwiefern ist denn, ich meine Radar hat ja nun den Vorteil, dass es eigentlich sich so von, also man braucht kein Licht, man kann bei Tag und Nacht eigentlich, kriegt man dieselbe Information, oder? Also das ist jetzt eigentlich meine Frage. Also inwiefern ist denn die Atmosphäre für ein Radar noch im Weg oder inwiefern ist das Radar eigentlich unempfindlich dafür? Muss man jetzt irgendwie die Atmosphäre aus diesen Daten noch irgendwie herausrechnen oder bildet die sich da gar nicht ab?
Also wir arbeiten ja im sogenannten Mikrowellen- oder Radarbereich, weil in dem Bereich die Atmosphäre oder die Durchlässigkeit der Atmosphäre sehr hoch ist. Gerade am oberen Ende in der Frequenz, also im X-Band bei fast 10 Gigahertz, gibt es da einen leichten Knick und den sehen wir mitunter schon. Also wir sehen zum Beispiel in unseren Radarbildern sehr starke Regenereignisse. Also so ein tropischer Regen, den kann man schon mal erkennen. Und zwar sehen wir einerseits sogar die Wolke, weil da gibt es so große Wassertröpfchen in der Wolke, dass wir Reflexionen an der Wolke kriegen. Und der zweite Effekt ist, wir kriegen eine gewisse Abschattung durch die Wolke. Das heißt, dahinter entsteht ein dunkler Bereich. Also solche Störungen sehen wir schon.
Aber die kann man ja relativ klar erkennen, weil man sieht auf einmal, der Wald ist zehn Kilometer höher.
Man kann schlecht korrigieren, sage ich jetzt mal.
Man muss es dann quasi nochmal machen.
Man würde sowas nochmal aufnehmen dann.
Aber man weiß zumindest, wo man nochmal neu aufnehmen muss. Genau. Also Wolken, Wasser, so die Atmosphäre als solche. Aber woher kommt dieser 10 Gigahertz-Knick? Also was verursacht das?
Das ist einfach das Verhalten. Da kann man halt in einem Bereich, wo eben Wassertampfe in der Atmosphäre oder Wassertröpfchen in der Atmosphäre dann mit elektromagnetischen Wellen schon wieder wechselwirken und irgendwelche Reflexionen erzeugen.
Das heißt, diese Probleme bestehen aber im Wesentlichen nur am Äquator?
Die hat man im Äquator, wo man wirklich so starke Regenereignisse hat. Also in den nördlichen Breiten eher nicht, da hat man nicht so einen starken Regen. Also da müssen schon sehr hohe Regenraten vorliegen.
Es gibt jetzt hier ein kommerzielles Interesse, es gibt natürlich ein wissenschaftliches Interesse, was wird am Ende der Mission dann so der Öffentlichkeit von diesen Daten noch zukommen? Also werden wir ein vollständiges öffentliches verfügbares Höhenmodell, was das bisherige Höhenmodell der Erde korrigiert erhalten?
Ja, okay, wie gesagt, es ist natürlich jetzt hier primär mal ein hochinteressantes und wichtiges kommerzielles Produkt. Aber wir haben uns eigentlich mit dem kommerziellen Partner geeinigt, eine Version mit größerer Abtastung, also wir würden eine Version mit 90 x 90 Meter, das entspricht auch den jetzt frei verfügbaren Daten von dieser SRTM-Mission, also von 2000, aber mit deutlich besserer Höhengenauigkeit erzeugen.
Und inklusive der Polar?
Genau, komplett global. Und die wäre dann frei verfügbar. Außerdem haben Wissenschaftler für eingeschränkte Bereiche Zugang zu den voll aufgelösten Daten. Aber der Wissenschaftler kann jetzt natürlich nicht große Regionen abfragen, aber ich sag jetzt mal, für sein Testgebiet oder sein Bereich kann er natürlich die Daten kriegen.
So, jetzt läuft das Projekt schon in der Doppelkonstellation seit zwei Jahren, hat mindestens noch eins, aber wahrscheinlich drei Jahre vor sich und wenn es ganz viel Glück hat, dann vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen länger, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Man weiß es ja nicht ganz genau, wenn so die Elektronik dann sich die Karten legt. Also potentiell ist auf jeden Fall schon damit zu rechnen, dass man unter Umständen so mehr Betrieb hat. Was gibt es denn da schon Überlegungen, abgesehen jetzt von diesem weiter auseinanderdriften und vielleicht besseren Höheninformationen, was man noch anfangen könnte mit diesen Dingern über das, was man eigentlich machen wollte, hinaus?
Okay, also wir haben eigentlich nur über Höhenmodelle geredet und in unterschiedlicher Genauigkeit. Jetzt muss man sich vorstellen, wir haben jetzt hier zwei Satelliten. Jeder für sich, die Technik an sich, es erlaubt schon viele Möglichkeiten, hat viele Moden an sich. Wir können unterschiedliche Aspekte damit versuchen oder unterschiedliche Experimente sogar machen und das können wir jetzt auch noch kombinieren mit der Geometrie. Das heißt, wir können diese zwei Satelliten, wir können die Geometrie relativ leicht verändern. Und diese Kombination ist eigentlich ein ideales Testlabor für zukünftige Techniken. Es gibt da Ansätze, zum Beispiel bewegte Ziele zu erfassen, Verkehrsströme zu erfassen. Die andere Geschichte, die Vegetation, über die wir so ein bisschen als Störung gesprochen haben, ist nämlich ein wichtiges Thema, auch die Vegetation als solche zu erfassen, die Biomasse global zu erfassen. Auch hier gibt es eine Technik, die die zwei Satelliten nutzt, Interferometrie. Und dann nutzen wir auch noch die Polarisation, weil unsere Wellen werden auch polarisiert ausgesandt. Wir nutzen die gemeinsam kombiniert und können damit das Volumen der Vegetation bestimmen. Oder die Baumhöhe anschaulich bestimmen. Solche Verfahren werden wir testen können, werden wir im Orbit demonstrieren können. Wir haben es ansatzweise auch schon gemacht. Im Moment konzentriert sich natürlich alles auf das globale Höhenmodell. Aber die Verlängerung der Mission gibt natürlich Hoffnung, dass wir hier noch viele schöne Demonstrationen zeigen werden. Ein schönes Beispiel, weil wir jetzt gerade Frühling haben, wir sehen zum Beispiel, wenn die Blätter ausschlagen an den Bäumen. Das können wir messen, weil wir nämlich im Moment, wenn wir drüber fliegen, jetzt sind nicht keine Blätter dran, zumindest nicht hier in Bayern, dann kriegen wir die Reflexion aus einer anderen Höhe, wie wenn wir jetzt in ein paar Wochen drüber fliegen und dann hier die vollen Blätter dran sehen. Das können wir richtig messen.
Das Rauschen im Walde auch noch aus 500 Kilometern Empfang.
Genau.
Ist denn dieses TanDEM-Flugkonzept auch noch für andere Satelliten-Techniken vorstellbar, also für etwas anderes als Radar, für andere Sensoriken?
Ja, also ich denke, was wir im Eingang schon versucht haben, ganz wichtig Aspekt von Radar ist Interferometrie. Das heißt die Nutzung dieser Phaseninformation. Und dafür brauche ich eigentlich immer die Kombination von zwei oder sogar mehreren Aufnahmen. Und die in möglichst kontrollierter geometrischer Konfiguration. Das heißt, solche Formationen, die werden wir in Zukunft auf jeden Fall sehen. Das ist fast ein Muss, das brauchen wir in allen Bereichen.
Also auch optische?
Also Radar, Radar, Radar.
Nur Radar?
Im Radarbereich. Im Radarbereich ist das ganz wichtig und das ist ein Vorreiter. Wir denken auch an Konstellationen von deutlich mehr Satelliten.
Also dass man quasi dieselbe Flugstyle mit drei oder vier oder fünf macht?
Genau.
Weil man dann einfach noch mehr Messpunkte hat und noch genauer ist?
Genau, so in die Richtung. Genau.
Dann wird es ja schon richtig eng.
Wir können ja dann, das ist auch das Macht, das haben wir mit unserem Flugzeug schon gezeigt, wenn wir nicht nur zwei nebeneinander herfliegen, sondern eine ganze Reihe, indem wir mit dem Flugzeug einfach immer wieder lang fliegen, immer wieder holen. Können wir demografisch messen. Also wir können in ein Volumen richtig reinschauen.
Ein Volumen von was jetzt zum Beispiel?
Von Vegetation. Wir können quasi Objekte im Wald erkennen.
Ah, in einem Walde sozusagen.
Fahrzeuge oder wir können die Waldstruktur erfassen. Wir können nicht nur die Höhe der Bäume messen, wir können auch über die, jeder Wald schaut irgendwie anders aus, die Strukturen erfassen. Das haben wir mit dem Flugzeugsystem, wir haben hier ein Flugzeug betreiben, mit dem Flugzeugsystem haben wir das schon demonstriert.
Aber meine Frage war ja, ist das jetzt nur für Radar interessant oder könnte diese Flugtechnik auch noch für andere Sensoriken ein Vorteil geben?
Ich bin natürlich jetzt hier, ich komme aus dem Radar-Institut.
Vielleicht hat da ja schon mal jemand Interesse bekundet.
Ich weiß jetzt sonst nicht, in der Erdbeobachtung weiß ich nicht. Es gibt natürlich schon auch andere Missionen. Es gab diese Prisma-Mission, das war speziell um Formationsflug und sogar bis zum Docking-Manöver, das zu untersuchen. Klar, wir reden ja alle von Space-Debris und Missionen, die Satelliten einfangen. Also da spielen ja solche Überlegungen auch eine Rolle.
Das Annähern ist generell ein Thema in der Raumfahrt geworden.
Den Partner, den Satelliten hier, der nicht mehr kontrollierbar ist.
Das ist echt interessant. Am Anfang wollte man erst mal nur weg im Wesentlichen. Jetzt muss sich auch noch auf einmal alles treffen und paaren.
Genau, wir wollen ja vielleicht auch Satelliten wieder auftanken, weil sonst der Satellit die Elektronik noch wunderbar funktioniert, aber der Sprit ausgeht, das wären solche Erkenntnisse sich auch wichtig.
Ja, TerraSAR und TanDEM-X sind auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen der Patans derzeit im Orbit. Haben wir denn jetzt noch einen wichtigen Aspekt vergessen zu erwähnen? Meine Notizen geben nämlich jetzt gerade keine weitere nennenswerte Frage mehr her.
Ja, ich denke mir, als einer, der sehr nah dran ist und auch in das System sehr einen tiefen Einblick hat, muss ich sagen, für mich ist es immer noch eine Überraschung und eigentlich eine wahnsinnstolle Sache, wie gut das eigentlich funktioniert. Der Formationsflug mit einer ganzen Reihe von Sicherheitsmechanismen, die jeden Tag in jedem Orbit funktionieren müssen und wir hatten noch keinen einzigen Aussetzer. Seit Oktober 2010 machen wir das Spielchen hier im engen Formationsflug und es funktioniert wunderbar. Das ist sicher sehr positiv und wir betreiben, also wir haben auch einen sehr stabilen Betrieb und auch die Aufnahme, das hat sehr gut funktioniert. Wir haben in der Auswertung einige Überraschungen überlebt, mit denen wir gar nicht gerechnet haben. Wir haben zum Beispiel gedacht, okay, wir beobachten jetzt hier mit zwei Satelliten, die praktisch am gleichen Position sind, ein Objekt am Boden und die Atmosphäre ist identisch, die ändert sich doch nicht. Der Winkel ist so klein. Die Technik ist aber so empfindlich, haben wir festgestellt, dass dieser kleine Unterschied zu korrigieren ist. Das ist eine ganz neue Erkenntnis. Also wir haben leicht unterschiedlichen Weg durch die Atmosphäre, durch den leicht unterschiedlichen Winkel und das bedeutet, kleine Unterschiede in der Verzögerung, in der Größenordnung von Millimeter, die wir korrigieren. Das heißt, wir erleben hier schon immer wieder auch Überraschungen. Das ist ganz klar.
Wie das mal so ist, wenn man irgendwas mal macht, was bisher so noch keiner gemacht hat. Wie kann man denn das zuverlässig feststellen? Ich meine, wenn es die Atmosphäre ist, die es abbremst, dann kann man ja auch davon ausgegangen sein, dass unten was anders war. Also da brauchen wir ja dann wieder einen festen Referenzpunkt, oder?
Das sieht man gar nicht, da brauche ich gar nicht den Referenzpunkt, sondern was wir im Moment machen, wir messen durch diese Helix-Formation gibt es nur bestimmte Bereiche im Orbit, wo wir vernünftige Basislinien haben. Das heißt, wir messen eigentlich im aufsteigenden Orbit, also vom Äquator zum Nordpol, messen wir auf der Nordhalbkugel, wir blicken immer nach rechts und die Südhalbkugel messen wir genau auf der 180 Grad versetzt. Und wir haben jetzt einfach mal diese einzelnen Höhenmodelle, die ich angesprochen habe, diese kleinen Höhenmodelle, die werden jetzt immer statistisch ausgewertet, die Genauigkeit. Und da haben wir eine systematische Verschiebung, sie sehen zwischen Nord- und Südhalbkugel. Und die hat genau damit zu tun, weil einmal ist der TanDEM-Satellit über dem TerraSAR und schaut steiler auf das Objekt und einmal ist auf der anderen Seite und schaut flacher. Und damit sehen wir einmal mehr, haben einen längeren Weg durch die Atmosphäre und einmal einen kürzeren. Das heißt, wir bekommen zwei Messwolken, die leicht versetzt waren. Die einzige Erklärung war eben die Atmosphäre. Hat auch genau gepasst, stimmt auch genau mit den Modellen überein und kann so korrigiert werden.
Das heißt, am Ende fließt hier auch noch so einiges in die Atmosphärenforschung mit ein? Oder ist das schon wieder zu weit?
Ja, wir kommen durchaus einen Punkt, wo wir auch Rückschlüsse auf Atmosphäre oder atmosphärische Parameter rausholen könnte aus diesen Daten. Wir sind durchaus an der Stelle, wo das möglich wäre.
Aber das ist noch nicht klar.
Nicht wirklich umgesetzt.
Aber das wäre so eine der Möglichkeiten, wo man vielleicht noch mal reingeretschen könnte, wenn man gerade eh nichts besseres zu tun hat. Wie ist das mit der Erdbeobachtung? Das heißt ja nicht nur, dass man die ganze Zeit auf Erde blickt, sondern man blickt ja auch aufs Wasser. Ich glaube, im Gespräch mit dem ZKI klang auch schon so an, dass man ja mit Radar auch relativ leicht so gekräuseltes Wasser und ruhiges Wasser ganz gut unterscheiden kann. Was kann man denn sonst noch so dem Ozean ansehen? Mit diesen Radarbildern, Höhenmodellen, in dem Sinne.
Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt, da gibt es schon noch was. Und zwar können wir in küstennahen Gebieten, das ist jetzt ein interessantes Phänomen, und zwar werden die Oberflächenwellen moduliert durch die Unterwasser-Topographie.
Das heißt, man blickt auf den Boden?
Wir sehen natürlich nur die Oberfläche. Aber die Oberfläche erscheint unterschiedlich, ob sie jetzt hier tief ist oder weniger tief. Und wir können so auf die Unterwasser-Topographie rückschließen. Also wir können die sogenannte Basimetrie da erfassen.
Also die grundlegende Tiefe?
Genau.
Nicht genau auf 10 Meter, aber man kann so zwischen 1000 und 2000 verschweigen.
Nein, nein, nein. Also wir schauen natürlich, wie gesagt, in küstennahen Gebieten. Das ist mehr so für Schifffahrtsrinnen und so gedacht. Wo man eben sonst mit dem Sonar langfährt und einzelne Linien erfasst, dann kann man mit unserer Technik, wenn man die beiden miteinander verknüpft, quasi das zweidimensional einhängen. Also ich kriege dann wirklich die Unterwasser-Topographie zweidimensional und durch die Stützstellen vom Sonar auch sehr genau.
Und kann man die mehr denn selbst, also Stürme, Hurricanes, das sind ja auch alles sehr mächtige Arten, die schon mal beortet wurden?
Nein, was auch gemacht wird, was zum Beispiel die ESA, die Radarsatelliten der ESA, die haben zum Beispiel einen speziellen Mode, den Wave Mode, was die machen, die nehmen über Wasser einfach kleine Bilder auf, so zehnmal zehn Kilometer groß, in Größenordnung. Und aus diesen Daten kann man Informationen über die Oberfläche, also über die Wellenhöhe, die Windgeschwindigkeit, ableiten. Und das wird, glaube ich, diese ESA-Daten fließen sogar ein in Wettermodelle, weil das ist ein wichtiger Input für, wie heißt das Zentrum da in England, das European Center for Medium Weather Forecast oder so. Die nutzen solche Daten in ihren Modellen, um eben hier Wettervorhersage zu machen.
Das ist eigentlich dann die einzige Methode, Wind über dem Ozean zu messen, weil man hat ja keine Messstation irgendwie mitten im Wasser. Und man über Umwege das auch noch raus.
Die neue Mission, die ESA bereitet da gerade jetzt den Sentinel-1, die nächste Radar-Mission vor, die wird auch wieder so einen Mod drauf haben. Also die werden über Land aufnehmen primär, aber wir werden auch über Wasser immer diesen Wave-Mode einschalten. Ein wichtiger Punkt, weil wir gerade darüber sprechen, wir können, wenn wir wieder Interferometrie anwenden, können wir ja auch die Bewegung, mehrere Strömungen erfassen. Das ist auch noch ein wichtiges Thema. Da sind wir auch gerade dran, da gibt es so eine Vorstudie für eine Mission oder so ein Konzept für eine neue Mission, um mehrere Strömungen zu messen.
Das ließ du sich jetzt aber bei TanDEM-X nicht ableiten?
Doch, können wir auch machen. Können wir auch mit TanDEM-X machen, haben wir jetzt noch nicht versucht, aber können wir auch. Da brauche ich, um die mehrere Strömungen und Bewegung zu sehen, dann brauche ich eher einen Versatz in der Flugrichtung. Also im Moment sind wir auf diese Höhenmodelle eingestellt. Wir fliegen fast gleich auf. Für die mehrere Strömungen wird man vielleicht einen gewissen Abstand einstellen, um dann hier wirklich entsprechende Zeit vergehen zu lassen, damit eine Bewegung auch sich ausbilden kann.
Also noch eine Menge Luft in den wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen und den Nutzungsmöglichkeiten. Auf jeden Fall Radar scheint grundsätzlich ein sehr heißes Thema zu bleiben, auch in der gesamten Raumfahrt. Wenn wir jetzt nichts weiter beizutragen haben, haben wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges? Nö. Also können bestimmt noch auf so einiges kommen, aber ich glaube, wir finden es jetzt hier doch nochmal dann zum Ende. Auf jeden Fall super spannender Einblick hier in den himmlischen Walzer, der sich da oben abspielt. Also ich finde diesen Gedanken da einfach dieser permanenten Möbius-Schleife, die da so um die Erde herumgeschlagen wird, finde ich irgendwie echt charmant. Also es hat einfach nochmal so eine ganz eigene Ästhetik, jenseits der normalen Ästhetik, die so ein Orbit an sich schon abwirft. Das war es, die 37. Ausgabe von Raumzeit. Ihr wart mit dabei und ich hoffe, ihr seid beim nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.